Iran's leaders are facing unprecedented
pressure from abroad and at home when an
American drone assassinated General
Qasem Soleimani sent shockwaves around
the world not only was he Iran's most
senior military commander he was also a
legend within his own country Iran's
regime vowed bloody vengeance but its
immediate retaliation seemed designed to
avoid escalation it fired missiles into
two Iraqi bases which host American
soldiers on Iranian TV it claimed to
have caused great damage in reality the
missiles killed no one but then Iran
made a horrific blunder its Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Corps mistook a
Ukrainian passenger jet for a missile
and shot it down
everyone on board died including 82
Iranians the disaster and the way it was
handled has sparked widespread
anti-government protests in Iran
it has also exposed cracks in the
country's theocratic regime immediately
after the crash Iran's government said
that it was caused by a mechanical
failure
they didn't admit that it was in fact an
Iranian missile that had shot it down
until the weight of evidence from
overseas made it impossible for them to
deny this fact three days later the
Revolutionary Guard issued a statement
admitting the mistake and the President
of Iran Hassan rouhani confirmed it on
Twitter you've seen a surge of fury
inside Iran you've seen people coming
out into the streets to demonstrate even
at the risk of being forcefully
disbursed and even shot at you've seen
artists and sports people saying they no
longer wish to be under the Iranian flag
you've seen newspapers apologizing to
their readers for having spread the the
lies of the government for so long
Iran's only female Olympic medalist
Kimia Ali's a day publicly defected from
the country in a blistering Instagram
attack on the regime in which she
described herself as one of the millions
of oppressed women in Iran Iranians have
been dissatisfied with their government
for a long time the economy is doing
terribly Iran ought to be a reasonably
well-off country it has a well educated
sophisticated citizenry it has a lot of
people who understand how to do business
it has a millennia old tradition of
trading and yet it's doing absolutely
terribly now this is partly the fault of
sanctions that have been placed on the
regime
but it's also because of the
incompetence of the government
protesters rallied against the
government in 2017 and 2019 in
provincial cities the latest unrest
began in Tehran Iran's capital and has
rippled outwards the kind of people that
we've seen demonstrating against the
government recently it's different from
the groups that we've seen before it's a
wider selection of people and it
includes a lot more established sort of
middle class people they're fed up with
their governments incompetence with its
brutality and with its endless banging
of drums for war when many people feel
that it should be concentrating on the
appalling state of the Iranian economy
prominent members of Iran's Parliament's
have retired and there are calls for
president rouhani to resign however
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei Iran's supreme
leader remains unrepentant the goings on
inside the Iranian regime are completely
non transparent and it's very hard to
tell which faction is up
who's fighting against whom and who's
likely to end up in control when the
ageing Ayatollah Khomeini ultimately
dies but one thing is certain the regime
is very unsettled by this and by the
reaction to it the plain disaster
together with the economic gloom has
tarnished the credibility of the Islamic
regime so what're arounds next steps its
leaders are clearly worried but they
show no sign of giving in to the
protesters many Ron Ian's are reaching
the end of their patience with their
rulers that doesn't mean the regime is
going to fall straight away regimes that
are prepared to shoot people which this
one is can last for a very long time
the regime will do whatever it takes to
keep its grip on power
it will also continue to stir up trouble
in the wider Middle East it will keep
enriching uranium which could be used to
make a nuclear bomb and it will probably
seek revenge for the death of Silla
money most likely consequences include
future covert deniable assassinations by
Iranian proxies in the Middle East there
could be a soft target an American
businessman a Jewish diplomat more
attacks on Americans might prompt
President Trump to withdraw more
American forces from the region if
American troops would pull out of Iraq
the country would fall apart in two
squabbling Shearer Sunni Arab of Kurdish
factions and that Islamic state might
come back in Iraq so that would be very
risky so lamanna's death has rattled the
Iranian regime ordinary Iranians are
sick of their rulers wasting huge sums
on foreign military adventures when the
economic situation at home is so dire
Silla manis legacy was to help make Iran
a global pariah crushed by sanctions his
death probably won't change that
[Music]
hi I'm Katie and I produce this film if
you would like to read more of our
coverage on Iran please click the link
opposite and if you haven't already
please subscribe to our channel to get
the latest updates on our films thanks
you